in the last video we named this molecule
using the common names for this group
right over here and i thought it would
be fun to also use to do the same thing
but use the systematic name so in the
last video we called this isobutyl but
if we wanted to do it systematically we
would look at this group we would start
at where it is attached to the main
backbone and we would think about the
longest chain of carbons from there so
if we start there we can get one two
three carbons so if we're dealing with
three carbons then this is going to be a
propyl group and we would number it one
two
three and we see on the two carbon of
the propyl group the two carbon of the
propyl group we have a one carbon group
right over here so this is a methyl
group branching off of the two carbon of
the propyl group so we could call this
we could call this thing the systematic
name instead of calling it isobutyl we
could call it two methyl that's the
methyl group right over there let me
write this down two
two
methyl
propyl
two methyl propyl
two
methyl
and so this is the systematic name and
of course there's two of them this is a
2-methylpropyl right over here instead
of an isobutyl we'll call it
2-methylpropyl and this is another
2-methylpropyl
so instead of writing instead of writing
the five seven die isobutyl here we can
instead substitute that with the
systematic name so let's do that let me
copy and paste everything else that
comes before it
so let me
let me copy
copy and paste it
whoops
oops i'm in the wrong layer of my
program let me go one layer down
so let me copy and paste it again
copy
and paste there we go
so i got that part but now i'm gonna
write this part differently
so we still have stuff
we still it's still on the five carbon
and the seven carbon of our main chain
so five
comma seven and we have two of them but
when we're doing systematic naming we
won't we won't say die this thing
instead we say bis
so 5
5 comma 7
bis
that says that hey we got two of what
i'm about to say
this
this thing
so let me copy
that's in a different layer let me copy
and let me paste that
this
this stuff
right over here
and then of course we have cyclooctane
and then of course we have
cyclo
cyclooctane
and we are done we have named it
systematically as well